hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 26 of 3d game
programming in Java okay it's Sunday
today and and I've still got steam open
for some reason so I'm doing get out of
that anyway so last last week on on 3d
and programming in Java we are we we we
wrote files to disk so in other words
what we said was on if we hit this and
hang on let me just get back to a get
back to reality real quick where did we
put it here we go sauce nope not sauce
resources settings we had where this
thing here and basically when we when we
entered this whatever that was there
when we saved it where's that program
when we saved it it changed into that
thing and whenever we try and load
whenever we'd open this it would
actually load that file for us and play
it for us as in like you know it would
it would I guess save our preferences
and that was all cool but the thing is
you know what if I do well did not mean
to open Chrome but what if I want to
actually change it here what if I want
to say okay you know what screw this
let's change it to 200 by 380 I don't
know what if we want to do that if we
hit ctrl s and we actually try and run
this then you'll see that it's not gonna
give us that is gonna give us 640 by 480
because what we said was if basically if
it doesn't work we said set it to 640 by
480 so the problem with that is that you
know obviously it's not very good also
what if we want to you know actually set
a custom resolution rather than this I
hate games sometimes they don't offer
you resolutions like cut all all the
resolutions that you would like for
example if you're trying to play the
game window it is to the fullscreen then
you might want to set it to a customer
as and you can't and the only way of
doing that sometimes is actually hacking
in and already hacking it but actually
modifying the text files what if we made
a few things like two text fields where
we could actually change the width and
height like that and
we can actually do that and that's what
we're actually gonna do today we're
gonna talk about a custom resolutions
and actually I guess setting this and
the reason I actually thought about this
and I was like well there's two things
we really haven't covered in DUI we've
thought of Ben
I guess this is like a mini series that
I'm doing now which is this is probably
gonna be the last episode of this mini
series where we actually deal with the
graphical user interface in Java the Jui
all the J components like jpanel J
button so today we're actually going to
introduce two more the jtextfield and
the J label again that's actually
probably it like there's more things as
scroll things the scroll bars there's um
radio buttons as checkboxes that stuff
is just standard though we'd only want
to we don't really want to deal with
that I guess we could have like a
checkbox to full screen or not or
whatever but yeah basically today by the
end of today's tutorial we'll be able to
change our heart our resolutions in here
and it will update and we'll be able to
change we'll be able to set custom
resolutions whatever they may be with
1920 by 1080 or 24 by 24 pixels you'll
be able to do it so um let's get into
this real quick it's been like three
minutes I always talk for like three and
a half minutes by the way before
actually selling the story also I'm sure
you guys getting used to that anyway so
cut I did I actually played tennis by
some hardcore tennis today again um so
what we want to do first is sort of make
I guess two text fields here right one
for width and one for height so let's go
private J text field make sure that tech
the J that the J the T for text field
and the air-filled are capitalized again
probably a text field will call it maybe
like T width so like text text width
text field width and T height and let's
import that again I'm just going ctrl
shift or and that'll automatically
import that stuff for us while we're
here actually let's create two J labels
again one for I guess I'll just call
this L width and Al Heights again lab
with label height again control shift or
o or I'm actually really
I've done what what's going on with this
by the way wow that is weird
first I can't find jailable and how that
is weird I think my eclipse is panicking
right now Oh all right let's just import
label automatically since it doesn't
want to import it for us you happy now
thank you I don't know what happened
there with Eclipse but honestly must be
like screen recording or something
shouldn't be a bit anyway point is we've
imported um four objects right now we've
imported two text fields and two labels
so labels I'm sure you know what like
I'll just explain it when once I draw
them on the screen so draw buttons
really isn't draw buttons anymore it's
more like actually we shouldn't be doing
this here let's get out of here let's
cut this code real quick and actually
paste it into our arm option so I don't
know why I started doing it there
shouldn't have handy it's really
convenient because when you copy and
paste off in the clips it actually
imports stuff automatically for you so
that's if you didn't know that anyway
anyway back to this arm so we've we've
imported these two things now let's go
down into here and say um what do we
have where our labels standard labels
first no we'll do the we'll do the
actual test fields worth first so our
desk filled width equals new jtextfield
and we'll just we'll do the same thing
we did last time we'll set balance now
we want to set it to a rectangle this
time I always do that but I don't feel
like with labels and text fields like
that's really nice sorry
so I'm probably just gonna set it to
about 80 away from the axe 150 why and
with an hi probably 60 by 2100 we'll see
how that looks
um and again we'll just add that width
into our into our window and let's copy
and paste that code because we don't
want to really retype that changes to a
height and again we're gonna change
everything to say hi and let's just
change the the Y to like
the wine no that's too like 180 that
should be fine let's check that out and
we'll seal that looks like alright so we
got two text fields here this again
looks horrible because we've got
basically two components here with no
levels and and this massive white space
here for no reason but um I'm not sure
why but um that's alright we'll just
leave it like that and it doesn't matter
you guys can fix it up yourselves I'm
sure let's add labels for each of these
so l width equals come on equals nu J
label and for the parameters will
actually put the name of that label so
the title of that label so in other
words with as the parameter for the
constructor and we'll set the bounds
again - now for the bounds dot set
balance rather for the balance I'll
probably just set it to like the 30 away
from ice again make sure the height is
the same as the one that you wanted to
so it looks nice with I usually just go
120 honestly that's just man-high
measure it's 20 said the text doesn't
get cold you can actually set font and
stuff like that but we're not gonna
really deal with that if you guys really
want you can figure it out yourselves
window dot and and we'll add our oh hang
on L with you like that and again copy
and paste this and put it right here so
we got all our labels for our different
things actually now let's put it here no
make more sense L labels are sort of
grouped in surah so are our text fields
L height equals nu J level and again
we'll just paste that and obviously
we'll change that to height well control
D deletes lines I'm not sure yeah under
any circumstance why you would possibly
wanted to delete lines for you but for
some reason you know it's what cliffs
does the other thing I wanted to say
real quick was let's just preview that
and we forgot to change the height 1 to
180 oh okay so now we've got beautiful
width and height right here as for
changing the actual I guess like what go
on as for changing the actual font
let me just you guys really could figure
out for yourselves
but if you really don't want to I don't
know I'm just contemplating whether to
show you guys how to do it I don't know
I guess I'll show you guys how to do it
again if you don't know how to do that
okay okay
I'm gonna show you guys a lesson in Java
right now that you will probably just
just remember this and you won't have to
ask me any more questions there's a
little thing called the API now you go
to Doc's at Oracle comm full-size java
SE a full size six full-size docs for
such api and you've got a list of every
single class in java version six there's
the same thing for seven but we're not
using seven seven looks a lot nicer by
the way you can say but um wheezing six
and that's my phone I probably have to
pick that up I'll see you guys in a bit
and I'm back okay sorry anyway so
version six and we've got all of our
classes so now let's get into which
class we're using by the way here we are
using the jailable class keep that in
mind and let's um get to here you hit
ctrl F this thing will pop up if you're
using Chrome or the equivalent in
Firefox Internet Explorer or whatever
Safari Opera I don't know what you're
using anyway pointers J label and you
can see it appears here let's click on
it and we've got a nice method summary
so this is a this is a summary of every
method that we used try this out we've
got a method called set bounds what we
use let's try and find it here
set Brown where is it
alright well lucky for you it's probably
inheriting it from component but point
is we can get individual we can get all
the methods that we want here now it's
actually it's actually probably a bad
example because jlabel and inherits a
lot of fields from J component from
component from swing constants from
image observer so the problem with that
is that if we actually go into here
we'll probably find the no we don't have
set balance rhythm weird let's do a
search for it if you deprecated things
yeah so it's from actually it's from
component it's not from J component so
here we go we've got a set bounce method
as you can see here that's actually part
of component and jlabel sort of extends
component so um that's why but we're
looking for a font type thing alright so
for like a I guess a set font type thing
so let's just search for it oops okay so
in J component we have a method called
set font check that out we've got a
method called set font in J component
the we can use obviously and it says the
font for this component so let's
minimize this let's go over here to J
label and go L width dot set font to new
font and we'll set it to verdana and
again we'll set the type to like italics
and the size like 50 this is just an
example let's import font and let's run
this check that out it works now that
bounds it sort of gotta balance but
check this out Wow look at that it's
working so I guess the point is that's
how you do it and if you have any more
questions make sure you can solve my
good little friend the Java API before
you come to me because this stuff will
help you out so much and you
you just search again control f is just
the best thing for this page but doesn't
Rosen support searching and what kind of
sock but the point is that um if there's
something you really want to do like set
the font search for literally font and
you will find everything you could
possibly want for that so that has been
a little lesson on on stuff what did I
have this app this I think let's try
that out
alright cool so now let's actually I
guess pass the data through this and
bypass I man I don't really know how to
pronounce that when I say pass it sounds
like PA SS but I'm meaning PA r si so
anyway basically when we entered this by
this and we hit okay we want this stuff
to actually do something obviously so
the moment does nothing as you can see
we want that the soft have actually
applied to the font so let's let's get
started with that um first thing I'll do
actually we've got this we've got like
this method here where it just it
performs this sort of stuff that's
actually caught that and whoops not all
of them and I'll make another method on
to this one so where does this one end
here I'll make another actually this is
no that's not the math of this method
we'll make a quick method called private
avoid um we'll call it a drop-down thing
drop and by drop I'm referring to the
actual um drop-down thingy what do you
call a choice called choice I don't know
why it's called choice but anyway and
let's pass all that curtain here except
let's take this these two outside so we
can actually use it and you'll see why
in a minute as well
all right cool let's make another method
except we're not going to set the type
to void here we're gonna take we're
gonna set the type to int and we're just
gonna call it pass with so basically the
purpose of this is to grab the I'll show
you guys the purpose of this is to grab
whatever's in here and do something with
it
so we want to grab this and we want to
send it towards the actual Rose
towards the actual setting that frame
width and height code so rather than
returning zero the moment as did that
one crash let's let's make an integer
called W W for width and again we'll set
that to integer dot okay first of all
what whatever we enter in that text
field is actually a string not an
integer if we enter a number into it is
still a string numbers can obviously be
strings if they're written like this
that's a string and that's and that's a
number so keep that in mind
integer pass int and we gotta get the
string type now our text field is called
t width this is just this is just we're
just doing the width individually here
we want to get teh width so T with dot
get text that will get whatever is in
there when this is ran so if there's
nothing in there it will get null if
there's something in there it'll get
whatever text is there when we run this
so okay this is hard this is hard to
explain but um again let's just return
null something for now what are you
doing can't return null tensor no it's
not a issue when we right now it's not
gonna do anything it's only gonna grab
what's in here once we press okay so
don't worry about it sort of if you're
thinking that that it might grab
whatever whatever is in that test box as
soon as we open it so it's immediately
gonna grab that and anything that we
enter after isn't gonna count it is
because it's only gonna get that text
when we hit okay so just keep that in
mind if that was confusing you so yeah
basically what we want to do is return W
but the thing is the thing is you have
to account for stupid people not
entering anything into those text boxes
or entering letters so that comes return
0 if we if we enter nothing in here it's
gonna give us it's gonna throw an
exception because you can't enter
nothing it has to be there has to be
something otherwise it physically can't
pass that integer if there's nothing in
there it can't pass knowledge
integer as you just soared it couldn't
return that type also people do this
then obviously that's not an integer and
it will actually give us a number format
exception as you'll see in a minute and
I'm actually deliberately not gonna
let's just returned I'll be for now and
this we should have actually kept this
career out of Norway put it here we
should have kept this code right here so
put that code back instead of actually
sending W they're less send pass with
that and pass height here now you'll see
that if I open up console if I what I do
wrong here oh we didn't make one for
pass hi my bad
let's quickly make let's quickly copy
and paste this I don't want you spread
out for now kind of an unorganized
tutorial at home I am pretty tired right
now options and we just entered
basically nothing into here hit okay
it's gonna as you can see it's gonna
throw us a number format exception
because asdf s is not an integer so what
we want to do is say that if some if
someone stupid just happens to enter
enter that instead of crashing our game
let's actually handle that so I guess
this is the real this is probably the
real first time that we're actually
using the cache method in this thing so
the catch sorry by method I in main like
function method I meant like technique
so we wanna try and catch this and we're
gonna catch and a number format
exception we'll call it a so basically
if we don't enter if we do if this
happens to be entered then let's handle
that let's first of all let's run drop
let's run the drop method and let's and
let's return W so let's return whatever
is in the drop method so in other words
if for some reason we enter something
here that's not right it's gonna ignore
this and go to this basically so you can
see how that worked and that did not
give us any errors whatsoever so you
guys might be like hey how come you're
returning w here engine and and
returning w here these look like the
same integers why isn't it crashing the
thing is this w is throughout the entire
class as you can see but this one we
only created in here right so in other
words you can see that we've we've we've
did we've defined it in in this try
thing so in other words whatever happens
in try stays in try okay whatever you do
between these two braces whatever
integers you define or whatever
variables you define they will stay in
here you won't be able to access them if
we call this HS and this HS and we try
to return HS here bump Bom it doesn't
work because it cannot be resolved to a
variable because that variable stays
within these parentheses so within these
curly braces so just keep that in mind
let's change this back to W so you can
have variable the same name and all
perfectly work for confusion purposes
though you might want to change that
I'll live does that because I'm not
easily confused let's get back to this
like copy and paste this code and again
we'll try it we'll change this to height
will change the actual thing to height
and we'll change this to t height make
sure you change everything by the way
before you come crying to me that your
code isn't working I say that in the
last way possible what's more like money
sounded mean so what we've done here is
I'm taking a drink by the way what we've
done here is one way out by the way was
as Charles been a while 21 minutes feels
like it's been like 40 minutes anyway so
we're returning a high it basically so
let's get back into here and actually
pass height all right cool let's check
this out let's set our width to 120 and
our height to 80 yeah okay play okay at
the moment we're still at 640 by 480 so
obviously we haven't actually done
anything with that code yet but if we go
into here you'll see that this has taken
effect but as we load this it still
doesn't work why
because we're not actually we are
writing that code correctly to this but
we're not reading the actual number here
all we're reading is always saying here
if I open up the configuration class all
we're saying here is if it's an
appropriate value set this equal to this
this and this so we're not saying
whatever is there
return it and that's not good because we
obviously want to be saying that so
we're gonna fix that is um well but the
way we're gonna fix that is let's go
into here and in instead of actually
this was actually a really stupid way I
don't know why I did it this way when I
did but I guess I wasn't I didn't care
for upcoming things we've got two
variables here that we're taking in
width and height if we actually right
click here go to references and hit
workspace we can see wherever this clot
were this is a really useful thing by
the way if you didn't know that if you
right-click on a method hit references
and hit workspace it will show you where
this method is called from within your
entire project very useful so let's
double click on this and we can say that
um over here the only the only mall that
actually they probably we've done for
this if we right-click here hit
references hit workspace then you can
see you know all the packages that this
is being used so we can say that it's
being wrong it's being used in this
package in this class and in in this
method in draw buttons we're actually
running that wrote that load
configuration method so that's a little
tip there but anyway so we're we're
we're passing these correctly so why
don't we just set display equal to that
why don't we so let's do that right now
we have this ridiculous code here let's
just delete all of it let's return hide
I'm still am just for the purposes I'm
still I still am gonna process it
through a method not sure why but it's
just the way I want to do it and we've
already got static with an ID methods so
let's set let's go back into
configuration and get rid of this and
and let's set display dot width equal to
width and same thing for high displays
out height equals height now height
equals height what's this going what's
going on here so we're setting displayed
up with equal to this width right here
as you can see clips conveniently
highlight stuff for you it's very useful
West where we're grabbing whatever's
inserted here and we're actually setting
it equal to the resolution so in other
words when we when we save that
configuration to the value of path width
so whatever we enter in those text
fields it's actually going to come in
here it's going to save that
configuration then it's going to load
that configuration when we hit play and
it's gonna find out what it really is so
we were at 80 by at 120 by 80s let's
let's hit play check that out
we're running us 800 frames per second
isn't that efficient at a release I
don't really look at a really low res so
let's set this up to something like 1280
by 720 it said okay hit play check that
out we're fully at 1280 by 720 with an
insane amount of lag but it works which
is on which is awesome so uh so cool
it's a lot of lag I might dedicate like
an episode in the future when we're near
when we're near to actually finishing
our game to actually optimizing this so
we can run the citizen frame records
this was a kind of laggy and again let's
actually just ignore that let's go into
the text file
it's already open it and set this equal
to like I don't know 1680 but let's go -
let's go small - like 640 by 360 so
that's 16:9 as well that's lots more and
let's hit play okay all the way around
but it worked all the way around this is
height remember it's sorted in
alphabetical order because age comes
before W in the alphabet by the way 360
by 6040 awesome so where are we here
you can see that the aspect ratio is
sort of being skewed a bit it actually
can't really tell anyway you can't see
that actually it's not
that's still a hmm that's kind of cool
whoops let's try and make this like ah
what's the width in my monitor like
1,800 by 360 cool check that out it's
really wide screen anyway you guys can
still running pretty fast 38 to 40 yeah
so you can see that uh we've sort of
we've achieved the awesomeness of
actually being able to set custom
resolutions now so let's set it back to
again okay let's try and enter something
here hit OK up and hit play way back at
800 by 600 awesome and again let's do
the same thing but we'll leave these
blank and we'll set it to 640 by 480
cool
what is this 40 by 40 but if we set it
equal to something but we enter
something here so like 800 by 480
whatever then it will set up to 800 by
480 so yeah anyway that is that
concludes today's tutorial next week
we'll probably move on to actually doing
a menu in game so like an in-game menu
let me know what you guys want out of
those 2 options I'll get back to the
actual game engine so in probably the
week after next week well same but would
you guys want me to decorate this and
make it look more like an actual good
menu not just like a GUI menu but rather
and like an actual like a Skyrim looking
launcher or whatever and this as well or
would you like me to actually make a
menu in-game so once we hit play comes
up with a menu where we can you know you
can we can use the arrow keys or
whatever hit enter and then it'll stop
playing the game so tell me what you
think about that first comment below let
me know hit the like button if you're
enjoying the series remember that it
really does help me out and a lot of
people have been asking for why movement
on the mouse and I do realize that the
problem with that is that I did I didn't
really when I was sort of thinking of
making this
I didn't really think about why movement
because of the fact that I've never
actually done wide movement in an engine
without OpenGL and the thing is like
it's clearly it's possible why don't you
guys have a go at it first of all it is
complex it's ridiculously complex the
amount of calculations required to
actually make this work properly is
insane because remember we have to deal
with first of all their stuff then we
have to move on to dealing with walls
and stuff like that it's a it's
basically a nightmare I had a quick
guard it wasn't it wasn't easy it wasn't
really getting anywhere but um I don't
know if if you guys really want me to
add Y movement into this engine then I
will do it but I was just thinking that
it might be something I might say for my
LW j GL series when I get around to
doing that after this series or after
another series that I don't I will say
in the future so um yeah but otherwise
for next week for episode 27 let me know
if you guys want a if you want me to
decorate this launcher and make it look
really nice maybe add music add
background music to the launch roll
whatever make it nice or if you want me
to actually make an in-game menu before
we actually start playing this so let me
know post comment below and I will see
you guys next week remember to like the
video and yeah later guys bye